بعد ان تحولت اجزاء كبيره من شمال سوريا
بطرفه عين الى مناطق منكوبه بقيت
المساعدات الدوليه خجوله لا تليق بحجم
اكبر زلزال تم تسجيله على اليابسه يقتل
المعهد الايطالي للجيو فيزياء خمسه ملايين
بلا ماوى في سوريا بسبب الزلزال رقم كبير
قدرته المفوضيه اللاجئين التابعه للامم
المتحده المناطق المنكوبه هنا في الشمال
السوري دفعت لجنه الايقاظ الدوليه الى
تحذير من انهيار الصحه العامه وسط تحذيرات
من كارثه جديده بعد الزلزال تتمثل بفقدان
الارواح بسبب نقص المعدات الطبيه اللازمه
وفق منظمه الصحه العالميه هذا الامر اشتكى
منه مستشفى ادلب واكد ان نتقطع لا تستوعب
العدد الكبير من المصابين اضافه الى نقص
حاد في المواد الطبيه والاجهزه
المصابين بشكل عام ووضعه سيء جدا بحاجه
الى رعايه طبيه فائقه بحاجه الى اجهزه
بحاجه لمستهلكات ادويه
لطاقتك كانت تكفي للتعامل مع هذا العدد
الكبير من الاصابات تحذير الامم الاخر
اطلقته يونس عن مخاوفها من ارتفاع عدد
مرضى الكوليرا في سوريا نتيجه التعرض شبكه
المياه الى الدمار بسبب الزلزال ورغم هذا
المشهد الماساوي تاخر وصول المساعدات
لتدخل اول قافله للامم المتحده بعد ايام
على الكارثه مؤلفه من 20 شاحنه فقط ضمت
معدات انسانيه وخياما وبطانيات لكنها
خاليه من اي مواد غذائيه واخرى ضروريه
لعمليه البحث والانقاذ